a pesar de que francia y reino unido-
rebajaron las tensiones en torno a los
derechos pesqueros pues break sit esta
situación podría estallar en cualquier
momento hoy se lleva a cabo una reunión
clave entre los países entre parís en
parís perdón para encontrar una salida a
su disputa pesquera como gesto de buena
voluntad francia liberó el buque
pesquero británico retenido durante una
semana en el puerto de le havre acusado
de pescar sin licencia dos toneladas de
vieiras parís se exige a londres un
mayor número de licencias de pesca en
sus aguas para ello para analizar este
tema lo que pasa entre parís y londres
en torno a la pesca quiero saludar a
carlos o murillo él es director y
también investigador del observatorio de
desarrollo de la universidad de costa
rica maestría en relaciones
internacionales con énfasis de negocios
internacionales intereses en derechos
del mar por eso lo invitamos hoy gracias
carlos por estar con nosotros en directo
américa de france 24 le pregunto el
origen de estos conflictos marítimos
pesqueros entre francia y reino unido-
sabemos que obviamente es por el break
sido pero que pide cada país
sí bueno primero gracias por la
invitación hay que contextualizar este
asunto porque es una cuestión de siglos
esa zona del canal al igual que las
aguas del mar del norte han sido
históricamente ricas en varias especies
de
recursos marítimos
naturales sobre todo de algunas especies
de pescado el otro elemento y por eso
hay que volver a ver un poco al derecho
del mar es que prácticamente toda la
legislación que hay sobre el manejo de
recursos pesqueros entre países proviene
precisamente de las experiencias que hay
en esta zona de europa lo que estamos
observando es una transición compleja
porque a pesar de que en términos del
comercio bilateral entre gran bretaña y
francia- y en general gran bretaña y la
unión europea el pescado no ocupa un
porcentaje muy alto si es un elemento
clave para la economía costera de estos
países entonces en la salida del del
break city quedaron muchos detalles que
ahora se están observando y que en el
momento de la firma de los acuerdos no
se les dio la relevancia importante y
también hay por supuesto diferencias
políticas que esperamos no lleguen más
allá porque no es un asunto sólo de
francia y gran bretaña también hay
intereses por ejemplo de
bélgica y algunos otros países europeos
que pescan en esa zona ahora carlos
estos detalles como ustedes bien lo dice
que están causando los estragos en este
en esta disputa entre londres y también
en parís pero le pregunto cómo se puede
llegar a una solución finalmente cómo
pueden ellos dirimir estas diferencias
para llegar a un acuerdo común que
beneficie tanto a francia como reino
unido para que no podamos ver en un
futuro
a la detención
si lo primero es considerar todo el
entorno porque no podemos perder de
vista que ahí está un un territorio muy
particular que es verse cerca de francia
pero que no es territorio oficio
formalmente británico pero hay algunos
acuerdos entre jerzy y gran bretaña que
son históricos el otro aspecto en
materia de negociación internacional es
que hay que limpiar la mesa de
negociación en el sentido de sacar otros
aspectos de intereses de cada una de las
partes para poder comenzar a negociar
sobre el tema de fondo que son las
licencias que son las regulaciones para
la pesca en esas ricas aguas del canal
entonces es necesario que las partes
dejen de llenar la mesa de temas como
por ejemplo e irlanda la parte
migratoria o sea otras cosas que están
en la agenda bilateral pero no son
propias o directamente relacionadas con
el tema pesquero ahora está que tan
lejos o cerca estamos de una posible o
eventual guerra comercial entre estos
dos países en este tema carlos
que uno esperaría que no hay esa guerra
comercial porque alguien diría bueno
pero desde el lado de américa desde
centroamérica y que tiene que ver estos
temas el asunto es que la economía
mundial hoy está tan integrada que una
guerra comercial por el pescado en el
canal de la mancha va a tener
repercusiones a nivel mundial yo
esperaría que no que después de pasar la
cob 26 en donde el primer ministro
johnson ha puesto mucho interés en las
partes puedan como dije limpiar un poco
la mesa sacar temas de la agenda y
centrarse en en un tema que es de
interés
a los pescadores en muchos casos
pequeños pescadores y que necesitan
superar toda esta crisis de la pandemia
todos los problemas de que han generado
del break sí y yo esperaría que no que
no se llegue a una confrontación en
términos comerciales ahora carro ya para
finalizar cuáles son estas consecuencias
que podríamos ver en el comercio mundial
debido a esta disputa
el problema de los mercados hoy es que
son tan sensibles reaccionan ante
pequeños ajustes que podríamos ver
incrementados los precios del pescado en
europa y que tendrían que hacer algunas
de las flotas pesqueras de mediano y
gran tamaño buscar otras zonas de pesca
y eso provocaría un efecto dominó a
otros mercados alrededor del mundo nos
afectaría entonces esto carlos en
américa latina' o no nos preocupamos
todavía por esto el así como un efecto
directo del man gran magnitud no pero yo
pienso que aún en américa latina hay que
estar volviendo a ver alrededor del
mundo que está ocurriendo en todo lado
porque en cualquier momento pueden
ocurrir ese efecto dominó que aunque
impactaría poco pero sí tendría impacto
además ya la pandemia nos está enseñando
que todo es global y con esta
globalización lo que ocurre en cualquier
parte del mundo al final nos termina
afectando a todos por igual carlos
muchísimas gracias por su tiempo por
estar con nosotros en directo no
sé si tiene alguna conclusión que
agregar no yo creo que sin duda en la
pandemia nos ha enseñado mucho y este
caso podría escalar a la omct y eso sí
tendría repercusiones a nivel global